so unlike our friend over here i'm a you
know connoisseur of both bitcoin and and
gold i got some right here um
but my question for you is more about um
so during the pandemic the top 1 saw
their net worth increase by 23 during
the pandemic and uh while the bottom
quintile quant how do you say this
quintile of households
of households increase their net worth
only by 2.5
and you tweeted that
it's price is not wealth that's rising
and people only have more money because
the fed created it stocks in real estate
are not more valuable just more
expensive and inflation creates the
illusion of wealth
where do you think that like you average
u.s household wealth is going in the
near term
well real wealth is going to go down i
mean for the entire nation i mean the
nation is poorer i mean we're working
less we're less productive people who
had jobs or not in the workforce look at
our trade deficits they've never been
this big
so this shows you that we don't have the
industrial capacity
to produce the goods that we're
consuming and so we're relying on
stronger economies abroad that can
produce what what we can't and you know
and we're focusing a lot of our
resources you guys will disagree with me
uh but you know a lot of the resources
that we have a lot of the manpower a lot
of the creativity uh is being focused
into the cryptocurrency industry which i
think is a complete waste and so instead
of funding industries that actually make
us wealthier we're just blowing our
money you know on what i believe is just
a fad and so you know we're just gonna
see all this evaporate
uh and and we're growing government
government is getting much bigger we're
on the verge of another
fdr lbj style
growth of government and a much larger
government
coming at a time when we're broke you
know when franklin roosevelt came up
with a new deal it was a bad deal uh but
we at least were rich enough to afford
it we were a wealthy country
back then uh and we were wealthy or even
wealthier potentially during the 60s
that was kind of the peak of our real
wealth and we've been going downhill
ever since when we came up with the
great society programs
but we're broke now because of the new
deal and the the the uh the great
society and stuff like that the country
is broke we used to be the world's
biggest creditor now we're the world's
biggest debtor uh you know we have you
know huge budget deficits and trade
deficits i mean so
we're now adding this huge cost of
government to burden an economy that's
already broke from having to shoulder
the burden of big government in the past
so uh this is going to uh make us all
collectively even poorer
uh and so you know people are gonna
unfortunately have to deal
with a decline in their standard of
living that is going to come with this
dissipation of wealth john what
questions you got yeah peter thanks for
doing this i see you again um
so
my question is what do what does an
individual do then right be i know buy
gold um
but
besides buy gold what what should an
individual do to protect their wealth
grow their wealth is it stocks real
estate is it alternative assets um
foreign currencies like what do you
suggest without
directly giving financial advice without
knowing their situation
yeah well i mean
what i'm doing with my with my own uh
wealth and with the income that i earn
that i don't spend which is the majority
of it
is i'm buying real assets i mean i'm
buying
businesses around the world
generally through publicly traded
securities
but these are businesses that i think
will do well in the future they're
almost exclusively outside the united
states because i think the business
climate inside the united states is
going to continue to deteriorate you
know as a result of higher inflation
higher taxes higher regulation
um
so i want to stay away from the u.s and
i also think american consumers are not
going to be great customers in the
future when the dollar is no longer the
reserve currency uh and so i want uh to
have businesses that have customers that
are in better financial shape
than americans are going to be in uh so
i want to own you know those businesses
those businesses have real assets uh
plant equipment goodwill you know
whatever they have and they generate
income they pay me in good dividends so
i own that i own real estate i own some
properties i look at buying more
property uh because again property is
real uh you know i you know i can use it
personally i can vacation in it i can
live in it or i can rent it out or
whatever i want it's real uh you know
and it takes real resources to construct
and you get the land if you know so i i
want to own real stuff
i own some physical gold and silver
uh just you know to keep dry powder
because i don't want to own fiat
currencies
because i think that they could you know
lose a lot of value even the currencies
i like i still think will lose value
because i only like them relative to
other fiat currencies that i like less
but all fiat currencies
are going to lose value right they all
sink at different rates and they're all
going to sink against gold now you know
maybe not every single year but over a
longer time frame
you know gold is going to be a preserver
of purchasing power much better than a
fiat currency and one of the reasons i
don't just go all in
on stocks in real estate is because they
may get cheaper in terms of gold in the
future and i want to have the dry powder
to buy more right i don't want to be all
in so that if real if you know all of a
sudden there's a big drop in something
and i don't have any way of you know
profiting from it or
in case i need some money for something
at a time when a lot of my stocks are
down and you can't just you know sell
your real estate at a good price
immediately i want to have something
very liquid that's not going to fall
very much uh that if i need the
to spend i i have it and so i'd rather
hold physical gold uh for that uh than
just currency although i still have some
dollars i mean i'm living in the u.s
even though i'm in puerto rico so i
still have some cash to pay my bills but
i don't i don't want to keep that much
in dollars i mean not you know money
that i'm thinking that i might need in a
year or two years i mean that money i
don't want to keep in dollars but stuff
i'm going to use you know this week next
month yeah i mean you know how much is
it going to lose in that short a time
horizon probably not that much although
one day it will lose a lot during that
time period i just don't know when that
time period is going to start hey guys
thanks so much for watching that clip of
the best business show make sure you
like and subscribe to the channel turn
on notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it